[Music]
this is the town of banal way it's in
the Philippines it's known for two
things
gorgeous rice terraces and these amazing
wooden scooters
[Music]
so in here Robert do you gain where to
hit on viewpoint
now if you go yeah and Moon are being
swept up between food and water Robert
and the other men of banal I used to
carry rice and wood by hand up and down
the steep hills it took forever so they
came up with the idea of using scooters
wooden scooters going up to speeds of 50
kilometers per hour
they're also revered as pieces of art
but he may Arkell she went up a hundred
a month daily and my nickel like three
every April you'll find the people of
banal way gathered together for the
annual embarrassed of all and it's
famous scooter race
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no big lure and neuropathy and discuss
always even when our my absolute nano
mundos de Nueva Esparta open period
South Korea - Elementary School
periosteum mikata Turkey the main event
is an eco wood interior panel patty :
after Ann Coulter in an Athenian Empire
of no nepeta Conan or Torrance - cotton
panel and TV any sport area hmm ah it en
hora en ta Baha'i area one window tell
Avanti tallest and merry tune panel a
tomorrow Onan or Torah when now
[Music]
[Music]
Oakland really will chew up and spit you
out like I guess nothing you know people
get killed every day you know living I
hope nothing is promised to me you know
so if I'm going tomorrow what legacy
what I leave behind my name is Tyrone
Stevenson also known as baby champ
discovery bike King and I'm the founder
and CEO of the original schedule I take
alright because it's my lifestyle I
don't know it just makes me express
myself even more
you work with youth that lives in the
community and teach them how to make
their bicycles for students you know for
kids to be a part of the team you have
to have at least a 2.0 GPA some of them
like it some of them don't but at the
end of the day they have to respect it
if they want to be a part of this team
we use different bike parts to make one
big one and make a look better back
basically fix anything on the bike now
Sky Ride King teaches you how to you
know customize their bikes put aluminum
foil and duct tape and spray paint on
the bike and you know make an ice
scraper bike is bigger than his life a
regular bike is just a regular bike I
ride scraper bike because I like the way
they look you get to show it off and say
you made it yourself
[Music]
yesterday was our grand opening of the
shed the first youth brand bike shop
ever in Oakland I found it the original
scrubber by team officially 2007
yeah my cousin Egberts so bittersweet
feelings to open up the show you know
just knowing that my cousin Avery isn't
around you know just to see you know
just to have his presence here because
it was killed it wasn't murder
[Music]
senseless in that I'm gonna do with
nothing I feel like this whole movement
is dedicated to him you know and I do
this because one day I might not be here
and somebody else could step into my
place and keep it going
[Music]
wheels come off baby low-res bicycles is
a special everything a special frame
especial wheels a special paint
everything is special the bicycles we
make is make with love because it's with
our hands you know those bikes snoop and
countless other rappers wrote around in
you know the ones that lose that West
Coast style lowrider bikes low to the
ground chromed out gold-plated they're
an extension of lowrider car culture and
they all started here I am The Godfather
of the lowrider bicycles when I was 10
years old the bunch of the neighbors
always dreamed with a motorcycle and a
car but since I was too small in no
money so I put my mind and bicycles a
mainstay in Compton and West Coast
culture these iconic bikes were actually
first created in Mexico I brought the
lowrider to California in early 80s and
soon after locals took notice of the
shiny swaggy rides hanging in a shop
when I started making bikes and put it
in a display people come and they say
can you make me one of those and then
they spread and now we have customers
from all over the world this is one of
the men's creators right here I almost
actually put everything on here blew my
mind when when you put it on here for me
it's completely different than the
regular bike and the way they look and
the way they drive
is art people's dream and we make the
dream come true in a city that loves its
bikes there is one man looking out for
the rest one man brave enough to bring
bike thieves to justice a man the city
calls like that man in reality I'm just
an engineer back in the early 2000s I
started really noticing you know there's
a lot of bike theft I read I said a
wheel stole and I was livid I was super
poor and there's nothing to do you know
I couldn't recover them it was so
frustrating for me knowing that the
police are so busy with so many other
crimes in Seattle that there was nobody
following up on these minor incidents
enough was enough
he realized he needed to take the law
into his own hands and he had the
perfect plan
I would best describe bike index as a
database that allows you to register
your bicycle it's a great way to search
for stolen bikes the way it works for me
is as improving Craigslist I'll notice a
fishy ad and I will immediately open up
bike index and do a quick search for any
bikes that have been stolen in that
geographic area the first time they
recovered a bike I had no idea what I
was doing I drove after work to go meet
this guy and
wasn't one person I was meeting it was
three and I told him you know guys the
cops are on the way I just called him
this bike was stolen and you're not
gonna be leaving with it eventually
threw the bike in the truck burned out
returned the bike and felt great what
began as a simple plan to help a fellow
cyclist took on a life of its own
Seattle's own bike vigilante was born we
were able to recover high 30s or low 40s
of bikes I'm not entirely sure win the
bike vigilante had become a thing it was
probably when the bike Batman moniker
was given to me and this is just
something you know I like doing I don't
need or want you know when your
recognition just doing good is
essentially you know how I try to live
my life
and thanks to bike Batman the cyclists
of Emerald City can rest easy once more
[Music]
when I'm out there riding my bike and I
have this pump on it's almost like it's
not even there
I just feel the freedom of being out
there and feeling the speed and
adrenaline I just hang out there riding
her bike so might say I'm like Dora the
Explorer cuz I'm always wearing this
backpack but this backpack keeps me
alive
[Music]
my name is Hannah Jordan I'm from Tulsa
Oklahoma I'm 15 years old and I'm a
competitive cyclist my long-term goals
are to become pro and be in the Olympics
in 2020 for Tokyo and bring back the
Tour de France for women I have an
unknown rare metabolic disease from when
I was very little I was in and out of
the hospital and very sick all the time
and when I was 9 they gave me only a
couple months to live it's like I sort
of skipped childhood my mom took me all
over the country so some specialists and
they found a solution and they gave me a
thing called a g-tube that pump sugar
into my stomach it basically keeps my
blood sugar at a normal rate I've always
want to do competitive stuff but for
most of my life I couldn't play sports
because my condition when I got on the
bike it was almost like my problems
weren't there it's just been like a
whole new world open up to me this one
right here is really special this was
her first one and it's a silver medal
but she did actually only been riding a
bike two months and then shortly after
that she did this one she did 101 miles
in 5 hours and 18 minutes which is very
very fast and that's kind of when we
realized that she probably was gonna be
pretty good at this this weekend I will
be competing in Tulsa tuff a three-day
race each day thousand racers compete
from 6 different countries around the
world these women are usually 20 and
above
my mom and my dad they're my biggest
supporters they take me to all the races
and help me make it in cycling my mom
she helps me get everything ready and my
dad at the 200 meter mark he starts
yelling it's like a mental marker like
when I starting to sprint what makes me
different from other cyclists is the
ability to tap in that willpower and
determination I like to tell people it's
sort of coded in my DNA to be a fighter
anyone that's been in the hospital for a
long time where's gone through some
struggles or pain or suffering they just
know how to dig deep and tap in and to
be resilient and even if you lose some
days and you win some others you have to
keep getting back up each and every
single time to go out there and ride
your bike
you